but let's talk a little bit about money
and kind of money supply and so you know
the US currency is based on a
inflationary model Bitcoin is obviously
based on a deflationary model just given
kind of again your experience in markets
and you know really taking this economic
perspective pros/cons
you know what do you think is kind of
your outlook on that deflationary model
and if it could work so generally
speaking we did a study of when stocks
performed the best okay and
interestingly enough they they did best
under moderate inflation interesting I'm
not high inflation but but very very
moderate inflation deflation
is a scary thing for an economy and if
you think about it for just a second
you'll understand why we are going out
and and let's say we both want to buy a
car and we need the car we need it for
our job we have we've got to get to our
job etc but we look at each other and we
say yeah but if we wait a month this is
gonna be like five hundred dollars
cheaper and so what happens in a
deflationary spiral is you lose the
confidence of the consumers and because
they think in their mind that wow if I
just wait it's gonna be a lot cheaper so
consumption declines precipitously and
people hang on to cash and so the the
you know the best-case scenario I think
would be if if the various crypto
currencies didn't have any you know that
they could truly be a store of value
mm-hmm right with with very small
movements absolutely in debt that's
really because what if you have a
different deflationary model at some
point take Bitcoin for a second 21
million bitcoins will be mined and be
available right some will be lost some
will you know people won't remember they
have them so there's some you know
circulation that is actually not
accessible but for the most part there
will be a set number and at that point
the logic I think holds that you know
there will be some market equal
equilibrium that's found right there
won't be kind of constant supply going
in or out of the system and so that
should be a decent store of value if you
can find that equilibrium and that
stability in the price yes theoretically
big if yep and so you know as an
outsider who just is kind of interested
in this and and watching where it's
going
i I definitely think a lot of those
thoughts you know III think well if you
really can't have something that people
look at as a store of value that has 20
and 30 percent movements because it's it
yet again to psychology yep if if if
we're getting all excited because our
Bitcoin went up 30 percent or we're
despondent because it went down 30
percent the fact is that does not lead
to a sense of certainty about it and you
know I think that's something that the
US dollar still has it you know I've
read all the stuff on how it's a fiat
currency and you know yada yada yada
debt crisis yeah yeah and and I'm not
convinced I'm just not convinced and
when we did the QE it had no
inflationary effect and it had no
inflationary effect because there was
simply no demand for that money it got
got put on people's bank balances mm-hm
and you know when when people understand
that they don't go crazy right and so I
think I'm fascinated by the idea of a
currency that can keep its store of
value I think the proof work concept
works really well you know I think that
the the whole delivery system and the
ability of transport ability and all of
that look I think if you
we're designing a currency there's a lot
of really good features yep of
cryptocurrency and tell write markets
treat it like a speculative asset as
they have been
and then suddenly everyone's just like
ah I'm not gonna do this it's almost as
if even if it is the best currency but
you lose the consumer confidence right
of not only price volatility right but
security right would be another piece
and then the part that I think gets lost
in this conversation a lot is the
acceptance right right so so even if I
can store value I either have to believe
that somebody else will one day want to
buy this from me writes it to basically
get out of that store of value so
another consumer etc but then if it's
money an actual currency I have to be
able to give it to somebody in exchange
for some other value see and that is the
magic of currency systems and you know
if you know your monetary history you
know that we've used things all over the
map as currency
you know clamshells literally yep
tulips obviously gold and and it has to
meet the criteria you have just outlined
you have to be absolutely certain that
if you want to buy my iphone from me
that I will sell it to you and I will
accept that currency yes a store of
value for myself and you conversely have
to have exactly the same belief yep and
so that's where I find this is kind of
interesting right because I think that
if if the crypto market had been able to
kind of be introduced with a little less
volatility because the one thing that I
do know from the stock market is
volatility terrifies
and and I don't mean oh I'm kind of
nervous here I mean people do incredibly
rash and silly things we had clients in
the financial crisis taking two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars out of their
bank account and putting it in safety
deposit boxes and and you know I would
be on the phone with them saying that
isn't gonna help you and so you know
when people are and we're by the way we
are all the same everyone sitting in
this room everyone in your family and my
family everyone we've ever known
we are human beings Homo sapiens sapiens
right that's because the new preak
frontal cortex but we are still being
you know and I can't remember the author
and I would love to give credit to him
because it's such a great quote but he
says something along the lines of you
know we are operating 21st century
software on 50 thousand year old
hardware and you know I mean I think
that just encapsulated we we just are
not optimized and so my my thing was to
say you know what I'm just gonna admit I
don't know yeah I don't know what I do
know that if I was left to my own
devices I would panic - mmhmm right mhm
because I'm a human being and I'm not
having been excluded excluded or excused
from that class and you know I always
shake my heads at the people who I did a
little experiment on Twitter last week
and I said I put a picture of the Wall
Street Journal from after the big crash
in 1987 and I said you're reading this
for the first time what do you do
well of course like more than a hundred
buy back up the truck no you wouldn't
but that's what's so cool about the way
the human mind works they honestly
believe that they would have mm-hmm
because and they don't understand that
they have hindsight and that
that happened 30 years ago and so it's
in the past and there's no emotion right
mm-hmm and so you really if you tried to
get into an argument with them you
couldn't convince them that they thought
that they were lying yep
that's the funny way the mind works so I
I definitely think that we are all
subject to these rules and and if you
want to understand any financial
instrument understand this human
behavior and interaction and then see
where are you in that phase